southern nevada health district
announcing more vaccines will be
administered at the las vegas convention
center this week
thank you for joining us at 6. i'm
denise valdez this will now
start giving people that second dose of
the pfizer vaccine in addition to the
moderna
as joe mohler reports today seemed like
a pretty busy day over there
he joins us now live with more tonight
joe
well today vaccines resumed after the
weekend last week
some people were having some issues
because they showed up here and they're
actually turned away because the first
dose appointments were all canceled at
the convention center well today
they did resume a lot of people say the
process wasn't smooth
i'm just thankful that this is available
actually linda culberson had issues
trying to book her second dose
appointment online
we were told to come to this
site and as a walk-in so that's what i'm
here for today
as a walk-in friday many were turned
away after they showed up for first dose
appointments that were canceled
tuesday people say it was a smooth
process a couple of weeks ago or for the
first one they had problems but
they have smoothed it out they did a
little bit of computer work and stuff
when you got
actually to get your shot that i think
could have been done in advance but
basically it was very good
the health district announced this week
they will start pfizer's second dose
walk-ins you can get the second
modernity dose no sooner than
28 days after the first and the pfizer
dose no sooner
than 21 days some people were turned
away after booking appointments too
early
you are encouraged to follow the date on
the card you received at your first dose
that was a piece of cake in and out
they're all set up they've got people
from all over the united states in there
to help out
the walk-ins are being accepted as the
health district knows booking
appointments is difficult
i let my wife do it lex anderson says he
booked at an odd hour
for us after like 11 o'clock at night
between like 11 and 3 in the morning
the computers were a lot more accessible
now we want to remind you that the
convention center here is operating from
8 a.m to 4 30 p.m but
walk-ins are only done until 2 p.m again
this is tuesday through saturday
reporting live at the convention center
joe mohler 8 news now